the reality is using social networks to
drive awareness really works because
it's free maybe you want to start doing
Tik Tok live cuz Tik Tok live is growing
LinkedIn I think is a great place for
you brother starting a podcast and
having people on it building awareness
and brand is by getting in front of
people attention is the number one asset
how about we start with some Discord
questions does that sound good that
sounds amazing but first can I just say
hi to everybody everybody tell me where
you're at where you're physically at
Aiden great to see you laptop Laura
always amazing we've got to start with
the call do it with me Jacqueline I mean
like course here we go 1 two 3 call call
there you go dust Dustin's in the mix
all right hangout Hawks hey twitch we're
on the hangout Hawk now um this is
exclusive for them so I'm going to have
to mute you but I love you all right
what are we doing we're going to get
started with some of our favorite
Discord questions we gathered from last
week and and this week all right so
Manny 1027 asks question on your backend
development of resi I am working on a
similar concept but creating loyalty
reward programs for B2B customers who
need help within the B2B space there is
so much integration that needs to happen
with CRM cpq Marketing sales to Etc so
okay he's building something like resi
on the back end so he basically asked
what tool types of development teams did
you leverage to help integrate resi with
the many different systems and tools you
would encounter with the Target customer
we built C we had a 35 person Tech Team
and built custom Tech to work with the
apis of every single POS product in
every
restaurant it was hand toand combat like
when you're innovating and you've got
different systems around the world for
something as
fragmented as the restaurant industry we
had to build API and custom Tech to work
with the leaders of all the different
softwares and SAS companies and POS and
it was it was a nightmare um it was also
a decade ago so you know it's been a
while now but um yeah that's I mean
that's what you have to do right great
thank you um our next question is from
Aiden advv at my agency we leverage AI
for Content writing ideas and Concepts I
just discovered that a couple employees
are using it to completely fulfill their
work SEO Rich blog articles they're
being paid a full-time salary and
quietly completing output in roughly an
hour a day while padding hours I've had
a suspicion of this and have asked
several times each time I was told the
only use for it is idation regardless of
whether AI content for this type of task
is good or bad how would you handle this
situation PS yes we're Building Systems
to spot these types of kpis
early you know I think that's a firable
offense you know if you've if you're you
know don't forget they've also put
Aiden's agency in a vulnerable spot
right you know I mean when people are
lying you know you know as tough as that
may be look Aiden you get to decide what
you want to do with that you know but
you know I would say I'm pretty hardcore
about not
firing and when something when I hear
something like that if it passed the
mustard of the things I would fire for
at at Vayner um you know how do you how
do you have relationships if you have no
trust break the law potentially don't
forget you sign contracts with clients
that you're not doing that um you know
so yeah Aiden I think I think especially
because you did the right thing if you
had suspicion and you asked people and
they lied to your face and put the
organization in litigation vulnerability
like you know you know yeah I would
probably sit down and be like let's use
Dustin who I adore he's family like
Dustin you just crossed a line that's
like I'm not sure where I can go with
this I even asked you and you lied to my
face not to mention you know I love you
and I'll help you get another job cuz we
work so close and travel the world
together but if I don't let you go for
something as egregious and illegal as
this then I've created a huge
vulnerability for the rest of the
organization so it would be a shitty
sitch it's kind of like I had to fire
someone who's like my real friend at
Wine Library because they were
stealing
stealing and I was like as a friend I
was okay with it like I was I felt bad I
was trying to figure out why um but I
still had to fire them because you know
you just lose such a level of
credibility um that you can really
Aiden's entire agency's on the line
right yeah that makes sense that's tough
um all right our last and final question
is from ail Japan he says I'm looking to
enhance the depth and quality of
conversation my Tokyo dad's podcast by
providing my guests with
thought-provoking questions in advance
what key prep preparation questions
would you suggest I ask my guests to
ponder before they come on the show
additionally Are there specific themes
or topics you think are particularly
crucial or beneficial to explore in a
parenting Focus podcast yeah I mean I
think I think this you know that's you
know and I I love him and so but like I
think that's the whole purpose of the
job right meaning like like every
interviewer is different like I like to
get into like real questions like I did
podcast with friends today how many
people watch podcast with friends today
say I did in the chat because then I'll
use it as a reference um yeah so you
know like you saw there was that one
moment with that hip-hop artist where I
like pushed him to be more vulnerable so
I I I think there's a lot of ways to be
an interviewer some people do incredible
depths of homework and like watch 15
podcasts with that person if they're
famous and like try to ask them a
question it's never been asked before
I'm a little bit more improv I'm more
SNL I'm more like want to know in the
moment what I'm feeling which is what I
think the audience is feeling and so I
ask that so I think there's no right way
I think what you want to do is know your
body of work as a podcast as a whole
right and so what you want to do is
create a scenario where you're making it
interesting for the audience in context
if he asks the same question to 19
guests in a row and the answers are
going to be in a similar place that
podcast is not going to be interesting I
think one of the reasons so many people
tune in to a lot of what I do is it can
really go anywhere even though I've got
my pillars you know I'm going to talk
about kindness and patience and like you
don't have to deviate from who you are
so I think there's a lot of ways to do
it but I think you know if you if you're
worried about the quality of the guest
remember so you want them to prep
remember that's really your
responsibility as the interviewer and so
like for me one of the reasons I
struggle as a podcast host is I can get
excited and interrupt a lot it's also
because I'm doing such hyper listening I
get excited and want to ask or add to it
or you know I'm a Jammer you know and so
you know those are all the variables
that go into something like that that's
great thank you thanks guys for all of
your questions can we can we can we let
everybody on and like hand rais and go
go to town and also can you too try to
focus on people who have historically
not asked questions if you if you can
notice when we go into that I'm going to
start
with Anthony M if you want to lower your
hand and
unmute can you guys hear me we can yes
hey Gary hey everyone um first of all I
wanted to just say thank you for that
awesome experience we have for the last
I call I mean I think I can speak for
everyone that was it that was a that was
a really great experience just seeing
how you operate in your like home base
it was really really cool so thanks a
lot for that um I feel like I feel like
we should run that back I feel a lot of
people didn't get to the office feel
like we you know Jack Corsa let's make
sure we uh chat that up I might want to
run it back one more time I feel the
extra energy of the people in the room
was a lot of fun and obviously it's a
lot of fun for people to hang out so
something to think about we'll talk that
through no
day awesome and then you know I can't
miss the opportunity to just say thank
you so I I came across you Gary I don't
know like six seven years ago I had a N9
to5 as an IT guy I started investing in
real estate that led to meeting a
property manager and I couldn't find a
good one started a property management
company and now I have a full service
brokerage during the pandemic I got my
broker's license and you know and and
it's funny I did all that until 2021 and
then I started using your marketing
advice so before that it was just on the
business advice and then the past three
years my my business has done a lot
better since I've been doing both the
business and the marketing advice so um
I just want to say thank you for that
really it's been lifechanging so thank
you you can't even imagine what that
feels like as a human being thank you
brother yeah yeah so um one of the other
tokens I mean this community is great
but I do have a fly fish token as well
and uh I don't know how comfortable you
are but I would like to ask you if
there's any real updates on that I know
the guys have been doing a good job of
updating us but I know we're getting
close it's we're getting close it's in
full I mean they're in Full Construction
like I'm visiting in a couple weeks here
like my guess is spring for I mean
spring for sure it will be before the
summer it's um it's rock and roll time
like we're going to it's going to get
really fun Anthony like I'm pretty damn
excited especially with like you know
the New York scene with zero Bond and
zz's clubs like I think there's this
really sweet spot that flyfish club is
going to find cuz some of the stuff is
like outlandishly expensive you know
membership and the amount of money we
put into the place and just just the
food uh I don't know if all of you know
this but we've opened a restaurant in
VCR group called little Maven it just
opened it's in New York City and like
I'm Blown Away by the feedback we're one
week in and the feedback on the food and
you know full disclosure flyfish food is
going to be an elevated experience from
Maven and I'm getting like you know I
grew up in the wine business so a lot of
people in the wine business in the New
York wine scene have already visited
Maven cuz you know in the New York wine
scene you're in the New York wine and
food scene and um I I could for
everybody who's in New Yorker or if
you're visiting New York for the
holidays please go check out little
Maven um it's um uh it's pretty exciting
so anyway Anthony they we're in Full
Construction a construction always
scares me we were like 2 years late on
building out Wine Library but you know
like I'm always scared of construction
timelines but we're very far along
nothing's in our way from uh executing
and so I think we're um you know barring
an atrocity
I think um the spring is very real call
it April May is my gut uh and then I
will see a lot of you there quite a bit
because I will live there on the back
half of this year I'm definitely using
this token to get the biggest table we
can get and do a hangout Hawk I think
it's a great idea by the way that's
that's a you know this goes back to
maybe on the last hangout Hawk session
maybe we'll have a bunch of people here
if the timing works and then maybe
when's our last Jack when's our last
hangout
Hawk I'll double check that for you
thank you yeah maybe maybe we do the
last hangout Hawk with a good amount of
people in the office with me and on zoom
and on meets uh be friends and then um
maybe that night a bunch of us will hang
out at flyfish so we'll work on it like
look I think I think this group
especially that's on right now probably
knows what I'm what I'm about to say is
incredibly real which is like I'm
uncomfortably busy yet I'm always
fighting for ways to interact with all
of you to the best of my ability and you
know so while respecting the acttion ACC
tokens and so um yeah I think that could
be
fun April 23rd by the way is the last
hang I wonder if we could like when I
hear that date I wonder if it's kind of
thing where it's like maybe we do it
there as like a first look because it's
not fully going to be done is or like
it'll be it'll be pretty that's
interesting we we'll talk Jack we'll
we'll come up we'll give people plenty
of time if we decide to lock something
in sounds great awesome thanks g yep all
right cool next question Jaden let do
you want to uh lower your hand and
unmute right can you guys hear me
yes oh brilliant uh Gary we met in
London year and a half ago i' never
wrote a thing on the internet now I'm a
full-time writer because of you it's
been a it's been a journey for sure um
I've I've been sat at this table
punching myself in the head as a new
writer um but it's taken off um I
started writing on medium um just about
crypto nfts um in fact it was after uh
getting into V friends I tweeted about
it went viral thought i' do some longer
form stuff on medium it's blown up I got
about 15,000 followers and I got some
crazy Americans following me it's it's
mental nobody J sorry I didn't need to
offend
anyone um as someone who's trying to
improve my right I'm going to go really
narrow and selfish that's what this is
for
yeah someone trying to improve my
writing and grow um I've sort of pivoted
into substack um yes and I won't say
reach to Plateau but I'm I'm in the
grind and I'm trying to build it what
advice do you have I think the biggest
issue yeah I mean are you are you are
you talking about driving awareness to
your
substack yes yeah I think look the fact
that you even said other than Tik Tok
makes me laugh because you know where
I'm going like you can't make up stuff
that isn't true the reality is using
social networks to drive awareness to
things really works because it's free I
mean here's some news you can run Google
AdWords around your topics and you could
pay third you know $3 to $7 a click or
50 cents to $15 a click and they can go
there and a bunch of them won't convert
and you'll spend $900 and you'll get one
subscriber and you'll be like why the
[__] did Gary tell me to do that like
you know social media content is free
distribution now now even hearing you
talk maybe you want to start doing Tik
Tock live so I'm not telling you Tik Tok
I'm telling you Tik Tok live cuz Tik Tok
live is growing you know LinkedIn I
think is a great place for you
brother organic you know LinkedIn uh
starting a podcast and having people on
it like it building awareness and brand
is by getting in front of
people you know so you know the reason I
love social networks is because I mean
Look at me now look what I'm doing I'm
constantly eating my own dog food I'm
literally [__] streaming myself now
in an ASMR capacity on Twitch today I'm
Alpha Testing it today another thing
another thing we put a lot of hours in
strategize if it's going to be right
affecting my life where I have to hit
mute on the mic and not on the mic and
like you know like all this kind of
stuff right like so you know LinkedIn
newsletter is a great opportunity I
totally agree Tyler like there's just a
lot of tactics but it's about more
content in the same way a year and a
half ago I told you to write and put it
on the internet now I'm telling you to
micro write and micro video and micro
audio to get to your longer
form like why am I going to why am I why
am I going to sell a crapload of books
called day trading attention next
because I built up awareness through all
the activities and then you push it
towards it
okay thank you very much
cheers thank you
Chad austerman do you want to go next
and lower your
hand yes hello hey Chad hear me of
course brother hey Gary nice to see you
great to see so I think uh I've told you
this before I have an immersive events
business and I really want to scale this
business um I'm finding it challenging
to get good profit from my custommade
made events with ticket sales and what I
really need is wealthy clients or
businesses who can pay large sums of
money for our services and I want to
know I can pivot my business model to
attract higher paying clients and I'm
willing to DM people post things I'm
just not sure where to go because I'm
used to you know like people buying you
know tickets for 20 $25 I'm I'm wanting
like 30 to 50K per event you know like
here it is do it you know so let P pitch
me the whole thing through so okay
you've sold events to immersive events
now you want someone to underwrite it
right in
theory yeah I mean like are you asking
cuz each event is a very different
unique theme
um well let's let's let's let's talk it
through like you know like yeah you know
if I'm going to answer you and they're
all custom what I'm going to do is
reverse engineer who the [__] would want
to pay $3 to $50,000 to underwrite your
event so as you can imagine I'm at the
mercy of the creative execution because
if you're doing something around space
well then you go to companies that want
that audience versus if you're doing
something around gnomes or Hobbits or
race cars so you know in reality what
you got to do is reverse engineer you
know the reason I'm good at building
things is because the only question I
ever ask is why why Chad would somebody
give you $30 to
$50,000 so I mean I guess my question is
how why are they gonna if I've never
done a space event before I could do a
space event but if I've never done one
before going to space companies you know
I mean I guess I guess that's my issue
is um people don't can't see what I can
do because well have you have you done
things yeah so I've done six or seven
events and they're all vastly wildly
different like do you have do you have
video on all of it yeah I do make a
[__] 90 second video Sizzle reel and
then you walk in and people know you
have done
[__] okay so then I send it do I DM
people with that reel uh well I mean it
it depends on like you know how you want
to attack this so again let's start from
the top like what event do you want to
do so um I mean I have so many I I just
got um a inflatable 360 projector Dome
where I I want to do an event called eat
like an alien where it's like a festar
dining event where I a different planet
good so like that I think you go to
people that care about the restaurant
industry okay you like again are you
telling me instead of selling tickets
where you might spend
38k and you then go start selling
tickets and if you only sell $1,000
worth of tickets you've lost 37k right
that's what you're trying to eliminate
right yes exactly
100% yeah so what you're looking for is
sponsors yeah and I don't know how to
get those well maybe you should go and
get someone to be a Salesman who does
know how to do that and give her or him
commission right so there's unlimited
people who have titles of like
sponsorship sales in their titles on
LinkedIn in and if you hit them up and
say I throw epic [__] events but I
don't know how to sell sponsorship I'll
give you 25% of any sponsor you bring to
my event would you want to take this on
if you ask a hundred of them then you're
more likely to get someone who can
actually do it versus you what you're
trying to do is you're trying to do
sponsorship sales and you're a creative
you're not a Salesman exactly yes so you
either need to get a partner who does
sales or you need to reach out to people
who do sponsorship sales and ask them if
they want a side hustle or freelance gig
and give him a part of the
action okay off part of
the and I mean I'm assuming I'd have to
pay them up front not necessarily if you
find the right person who believe like
when I by the way right off the top you
got my attention the fact that you just
pinch pitched me you want to do a popup
event that is based on eating like an
alien that's [__] clever thank you
right so like like you know if I'm a
sponsorship salesperson who's pretty
accomplished has a big role of X and I
happen to hear that pitch and I'm like
wait a minute I got a perfect bunch of
people I might just take the I might I
might counter you and say give me 33%
instead of 25% of the action you're
going to say yes then I'm going to go
sell at $100,000 sponsorship and keep
33,000 just cuz I know the one person CU
that's what I do so you know you may not
have to pay someone up front there's
plenty people that work on commission
only you just got to find them that's
who you need to be messaging on LinkedIn
not trying to come up with brand you
like that's like asking a Salesman to
come up with the creative idea of eat
like a like an
alien no exactly no 100% okay thank you
reach out to sponsorship people that's
awesome appreciate you sponsorship
salese sponsorship sales people thank
you amazing um Monica Wilkins do you
want to go next you want to unmute and
lower your hand hello can hear we can
yes hi Gary hi Monica
the um
okay B it everyone um I have a small
business I mean I have a business
services company that um basically
caters to small businesses so um I kind
of fill in the gap for if you don't need
a full-time employee um I do any type of
work if you need bookkeeping for or if
you need no matter what you need um you
always talk about Niche finding your
niche um do you have to have a niche or
is is small business good enough because
I don't want like I despise corporate I
absolutely hate that yes small business
is enough of a niche so okay so um
because I actually like all different
aspects of business me too I have like
1,700 companies because I like it all
okay so but I I was always struggle when
you say um to find your Niche and I'm
like I like I'm you know what's so you
know you know what you know what's so
funny
show me the clip where I've said to find
your
Niche Gary I don't know I'm sure it's
there ask Corso no no no no be careful
there's a there's a Gary ve search
engine go type in to find your need go
find It Go show me there's a lot of
crazy hardcore Gary ve fans here I have
a very funny feeling that a lot of you
are going to back me up on this I am not
a big Define your Niche I'm a you are
your Niche guy like I'm we' talk so all
of you people shaking your head I don't
I mean I mean anony don't yall do that
to me because he said is St okay so
that's good because that that is kind of
my Niche and I don't I love to help the
people that are you know I don't I don't
even I actually don't even understand
what you're saying meaning it sounds
like you're happy and you're
building why would what what do you I
don't want to focus solely on
bookkeeping I don't want to solely focus
on business management or like branding
or like social media I just want it to
be broad for the you want to do small
business Consulting and you will come
and by the way let me give you a
business model I will come and audit
your business to tell you what you
should do with me so you're going to pay
me $5,000 just for my time to understand
everything and then I'll tell you
pricing on all these other things I feel
I can help you
with exactly that is perfect yes I cuz I
love the full range of of services and
I've already scaled as far as the things
that are taking me you know too much
time that of course I can do because I
want to be able to do everything in the
business not just I don't want to do
something I can't do myself I get it um
so I've hired people for different
things like that so I just want to make
sure that I'm on the right page there
and then the only other thing um as far
as scaling and then using people um out
of the country my good friend Robert had
um the on here has um hooked me up with
some different people um that I can use
do I just hide the fact that I'm using
someone out of the country because a lot
of people are not comfortable with that
yeah mean and I personally I'm betting
the person for a few months before
honestly I yeah I genuinely yeah I
genuinely think that that's a personal
decision right like you know at the end
of the day if you are if anyone asks you
directly if you're using subcontract you
have to answer honestly as far as as far
as do you need to lead with that I'm not
necessarily sure you have to I think I
think there's a very strong argument
that I've heard from both sides of the
equation on this and I think you're
allowed to decide what works for you
Monica I don't think that's I don't
think there's a right or wrong to that
you know Robert says I would say no you
know like you don't have to do that
Monica other people I've talked to feel
very passionate that you should I'm I'm
agnostic on this one I don't I think
this is more of when it starts blurring
into like does one think this is a moral
issue or not that's where it gets a
little complicated and so I think I'm
incredibly comfortable with you deciding
what's right for you and and there is no
right answer on that okay perfect thank
you thank you um
Michelle would you like to go okay there
we go I'm in can you hear me I can
Michelle okay great Gary um so I'm super
excited to be here my my friend Benny
fiser gifted me his seat today very nice
and I want to thank you I want to thank
you Michelle because if Benny was here
he would be disruptive and eating up the
oxygen and so I can I can say this for
all the Hawks we are estatic that you
are here Michelle let's all clap it up
for
Michelle preparation don't suck up the
air in the room get to the point right
so okay you've trained him well so
listen my question today is around
kindness so for the last 20 years my
teams and I have adopted families at
Christmas this is the perfect time for
me to have a guest seat with you um
about 5 years ago I wanted to move away
from just buying Christmas presents and
supporting families like we adopt
families from domestic violence shelters
and really move into other Seasons like
they need help if they need help at
Christmas they need summer clothes they
need back to school clothes and I wanted
to know how I could do that with more
impact so just you know thinking about
like how could I do this with more
impact I had an idea aidea and I started
collecting Kohl's cash and Old Navy Cash
you know the cash that we get but we
never remember that it's in our wallet
and it literally doesn't get used um for
example Old Navy they will give you
super cash you spend $25 you get $10
back right and then it goes unused so I
had this idea that my team and I would
collect the fake cash and the rewards
from our client base from my
entrepreneur communities and we would go
out and actually use that cash to buy
more Goods to do better you know do more
good in the world so I've been doing
that for the last eight years I know the
impact has made a huge difference in not
just picking a family in their wish list
at Christmas but really Amplified to
what we're doing throughout the year and
now I want to share the idea the H the
the why the What the how with others
across the country so we can actually
amplify the the giving right and what's
so beautiful about it is that no one has
to write a check like you could
literally just develop a team in your
community your school School your
wherever you are and somebody can just
simply activate the campaign somebody
can do the shopping and other people
it's Time treasure talents right you can
you can you can show you can show
everybody how to do the blueprint of it
yeah yeah so I want to call it like cash
back heroes or something like that um
and really I'd love to hear whether you
have any advice on how to take this from
where it is today which is me and my
team not a nonprofit or anything like
that at this point and to a larger scale
like what Tony Robbins did with the
basket
brigades I mean Tony spent 30 years of
building a reputation have a platform so
he was able to amplify it yeah I mean
this is all the same game you know
Michelle it's like how do you build
awareness it's like the you know I was
at the charity water Gala the other
night like it's all storytelling what's
up am going to sleep you're waving
you're going to
sleep um you know Michelle I think look
it's it's hand-to-hand combat it's hand
toand combat like every everyone's
looking for this especially when they're
doing things for good I always I talk to
a lot of nonprofits it's something that
I am passionate about you know I sit on
multiple boards but I take a lot of
meetings and do a lot of spec work and
Consulting and I the the issue with
people that are doing good is this is a
very very very very distinct sentence
that I'm about to
say because they're doing something
remarkable they're audacious in their
expectation of others and they lack
empathy that people have different
things that they want to support and
just because you're doing something good
doesn't mean that you're supposed to
give their attention Andor money to
someone yeah so I get that yeah and I
see it a lot like it really [__] with
good people like yourself it's like
they're like they don't realize they're
judging people without knowing people
every you there are multiple people here
on this like when I hear what you're
saying it like strikes me right down the
center you're like wonderful it's
amazing yet it's pretty cool right it's
very cool yeah you know Meanwhile my
parents are driving my brother home
right now from a colonos because AJ has
Crohn's disease and my parents are still
driving him I'm what 40 at 37 years old
to his colonoscopies cuz it's incredibly
emotional to them and they want to take
their energy time and money and support
that right and then everyone here has
all sorts of [__] going on right and I'm
sure you know you know there's just so
much and and so you know I think the
first thing you have to do is first make
sure that you know that you have to
battle for attention and awareness just
like everyone else and every celebrity
and every entity that you go to they get
asked 4,000 times I was asked to give
money in
donation 1,700 times in the month of
November in direct email not even DMS
yeah that's huge just but just think
about what that means right like I'm
just trying to put it into perspective
of the asks and I'm not the most famous
guy so just the hell yeah you are so
what I'm what I'm saying is you know
couple things you need to build a
Communications infrastructure you know
and you need to figure like the reason I
love Tik Tok is you make one video with
one feel-good story and it gets 39
million
views the The Good Good Morning America
can't do that for you Oprah tweeting
can't do that for you like people don't
understand it's a social media strategy
World social media content gets free
distribution do you know insane that is
the first 15 years of social media these
companies that I invested in Facebook
and Twitter and all that that was more
like email you would have to amass
followers for a long period of time then
you would post and a percentage of them
would see it the social media we live in
now with these AI algorithms is you make
one good piece of content and your life
changes so you have to become remarkable
at making
content challenge accepted love you all
right thank you my friend thank you back
thank you Michelle um Jin do you want to
go
next yes I'm here perfect G happy
Tuesday everyone happy
Tuesday first and foremost I want to
thank John for giving me the opportunity
of a spot today um to be able to talk to
you Gary um so uh I'm the team officer
are premium shots and what we do is we
deliver memorable immersive photo video
related experiences for corate and
social events uh we've been honored to
work with some big names in sports like
the Golden State Warriors um NBA 2K the
49ers and even My Hometown Heroes the
Sacramento Kings it's crazy how my
journey began at Von last year in
Minnesota um where you inspired me to
resign from my 21-year government job
last August to pursue my business
full-time that I started back in 201 17
thank you so much Gary and been very
extremely grateful for this opportunity
um to uh listen to you and inspire me to
take a leap of faith to do what I love
for my family thank you brother and um
I've been working to build relationship
to the web three space um it would be
such an honor to be able to work with
the future owner of the New York Jets
and the awesome Vayner X crew to provide
an epic photo activation for vcon
2024 um an example I can I can just jump
in like feel free to send me an email as
you can imagine I see it I see the card
we're happy to look at it we're looking
at everything no different than the 1700
I actually had my admins do it the 1,700
nonprofit requests I don't know if
there's a day that doesn't go by that we
don't get 25 to 50 vendor requests to
activate a vcon so I don't have enough
details to know who Mouse in the
community other vendors other things
that are going on but if you send me an
email personally to Gary ATV friends and
put it jabon from The Hangout hog
session with all your information I will
absolutely get it looked at and analyzed
in comparison to the other things we're
doing yes sir I appreciate your time
here of course my man thank you man
super humbled by the emotion and the
kind words that you displayed just now
appreciate that how how are we feeling
about the Kings this year you guys got a
pretty real
Squad we do um it's like I said I I
provided um multiple activations for the
Kings um during the playoffs this year
for all seven games and that led me to
uh working with the Universal Pictures
um we're providing experience for all
their movie Red Carpet Premier Events so
it's awesome just truly humbled with
opportunity to be able to work with such
big Brands I can't wait to dig under the
hood Brad thank
you thank you thank you Jin um Dr
Malachi W to unmute there we go doc got
it got it it was me so Gary let me just
say first had I had the chance to
playing basketball at Chuck-E-Cheese I
would have beat you I doubt that very
much
doc okay so hey you've interviewed so
many I disagree but anyway you
interviewed so many amazing doc doc I I
disagree back I I hear your disagreement
and I match it with greater disagreement
I then take that disagreement and
dismantle it with my
disagreement I put all my chips on the
table and say Von pick anything you want
I'll beat you at it
I will do that and we will live stream
it and after I beat you I will
physically hurt
you and I will live stream that and um
sue me all right go ahead doc yeah okay
so um obviously you've interviewed
amazing people proximity is amazing I I
guess this is a two-fold question answer
it if you want is there something
amazing that you've seen as a
commonality amongst some of the amazing
people you've interviewed and then two
too because I'm also a major Tony
Robbins fan um and he's had a major
influence in my life is there something
about Tony that maybe six out to you
because he's the best of the best at
what he does you've done stuff with him
that SS out to you like are there things
of people that make you Aspire not just
motivate you but
Aspire uh I'll do the Tony part first I
mean I think Tony has achieved what a
what I see a lot of people as well which
is I think Tony does what Tony was
supposed to do
do you know what I mean like this goes
back to why I'm obsessed with
self-awareness and obviously there's
examples of like Tony and Kobe and all
other people but then I also my mom is
that person my mom was meant to be a
mother and like no [__] there's no
one who's done it better it may not get
the headlines it may not get the public
Awards many people may not know it
obviously I've been a loud advocate for
her and so many more people know it but
you know
I love seeing people when they're doing
what they're supposed to do and that's
what stands out for Tony as far as yeah
I have a very very distinct answer for
you brother the people that you're
referring to in question one have all
gotten to their place in the world based
on one of two extremes deep deep deep
insecurity or deep deep deep self-esteem
and
gratitude it's a wild ass thing for me
at 48 to see how clear this is the
people that achieve outsized results
that then allow the masses to look at
them it's [__] Star Wars
Doc it's literally Jedi and and and Sith
Lords it's like the good and the bad at
extreme
levels but just like Star Wars like it's
not sustainable when you're on a dark
side it's why so many famous and
successful and we leite people have such
dramatic burnouts deaths suicides like
these supernovas like think about all
the my friends think about all the most
famous artists and comedians that pass
away at such young ages it was the dark
side that got them there this is why I
talk about we can't put money on a
pedestal too many people get to money
through jealousy envy and
negativity yeah doc I'll tell you the
thing that completely binds everybody
that I've ever interviewed or anybody
I've ever seen up close and I've seen a
lot of them
of wealth and fame it's either light or
dark and [__] bad news most of it's
dark I think it's why I'm so compelled
to communicate about the things that I'm
talking
about it takes more time and it's more
challenging to like not that's not true
let me say it differently it's just
unfortunate that it takes super fuel to
get you to the top that's not
unfortunate makes sense it's just
unfortunate that most people's super
fuel is coming from a place of
resentment or a chip on a shoulder I'll
show you mom dad you know like
girlfriend boyfriend husband like it
it's unfortunate like I almost you know
what it's funny I made this analogy to a
friend a couple years ago I haven't
thought about this since and this is the
only time I've ever said it publicly
something happened to me where I
understood my fuel was weird and
different than all the other people in
my 20s and 30s and I compared it to like
going to the gas station where there was
like the weird like diesel fuel pump and
everybody else had the normal [__] and I
was like I'm the diesel fuel like I feel
like I'm getting here on a different
energy length and
um yeah I I'd want more people to get to
the top through gratitude and kindness
and empathy and compassion and Civility
and patience and that's why vriends
exist because I know I can't scale it by
myself great and thanks for everything
because you are rare in your willingness
to just interact and be accessible and
be encouraging and be authentic when you
do so my hats off to you and thank you
and again Von will be the end for
you doc it was really nice to see you at
Chuck-E-Cheese especially because we've
been interacting for so
long thank you Dr Malachi um V would you
like to go
next yes uh hi hi Gary Hi how are you
I'm good G how are you I'm quite well my
friend okay so it's um so my question is
um so I believe my first interaction
with you was um I uh I went vegan and
you asked me uh are you doing okay and
uh that was the I hope you remember that
so it's been 3 and a half years and I've
still continued doing the same um I've
progressed in my fitness journey too um
I wanted to do 75 hard challenge uh uh
I'm sure you've heard about it
or have you know yes I
have okay so um so regarding like Monica
spoke about some niches and uh I know
that one should not believe in them but
I personally feel I do have some like
not many Indians are vegans uh second uh
in India people don't know how to get
protein from even vegetarian foods but I
do know being a vegan you can have
enough protein
um also like so you know I B real quick
just while I've got you um and we're
talking um I'm not I'm not saying that
people shouldn't be Niche and things of
that nature I'm saying that it's not the
only way so many people think they have
to be and sometimes your Niche is you
like I you know many people most people
are successful because they're known for
something or have gone deep in something
but there's people like Monica and I
that want to do a poper of things but
going niches is incredibly powerful as
you know it's the majority of everyone
who accomplishes
something got it so if you have them use
them yeah especially the way you are
talking about this this is like a
passion of yours true this goes back to
what I just said earlier like how people
get there passion is one way like if you
like it this is the [__] up thing
about the world people don't want work
ethic to be part of the equation it's
hard for people to accept the amount of
hours it takes to build something
meaningful in parenting in business in
the world it's it's it's daunting for
many um but it is fully fully a part of
it and the way I think most people are
able to achieve the work ethic to do
something special is they like it so it
doesn't feel like work right it just you
know when you say that uh I resonated
with with it because my wife was
thinking wouldn't it be too difficult
for you to do 75 hard and I'm on the
other hand thinking no like that will be
the uh I really want to do that because
I've noticed myself being disciplined
with my diet and workout so uh yeah so
my question is I was thinking about
YouTube shs and the same thing on uh
Instagram as well and I wanted to use
Hindi the
Indian language because in in India like
the masses and they will be able to
relate with me better so even though I'm
in the US I was thinking I'll choose the
I think that's right so so any anything
else apart from this that you would like
me to try doing yeah I mean it's it's
why I'm writing the new book it's best
practices I want you to think about your
titles I want you to think about your
thumbnail I want you to think about the
first three seconds of your video I want
you to think about mixing English and
Hindi in the same video we see that
Spanglish
crushes right so when people speak half
Spanish half English you know I want you
to think about what time you post the
copy that you're using to support the
post this is a [__]
science
right so the platforms would be like
YouTube sh same thing on Instagram and
Tik Tok you know the reality is any
platform can work do you know what team
guess in the comments my fastest growing
platform right now and you know that
these are all not like it's a small
platform and like you know I only had 30
people and now I have 80 people I'm at
scale on all of them what is my fastest
growing
platform Linkin so a lot of LinkedIn
answers Tik Tok the answer to the
question and it's not even
close
Facebook crushing gaining thousands of
thousands of followers a week best
practices I'm using the default type and
we're putting quotes in with the default
type um posts and like it just it's just
so [__] odd obvious that it's an an
everyday this is why I'm writing the
book day trading V the answer is as
whichever platform most works for you
like like I can't push all of you enough
towards Tik Tok live I can't push you
all enough towards um YouTube but
meanwhile like it might be Facebook it
might be LinkedIn it might be Twitter X
like all of you are going to be better
at certain platforms than others some
come more native to each of us than
others right so cam I'm using cam cam
just asked I'm sorry one second cam cam
just asked how am I using Facebook I'm
posting on my Facebook page but I'm but
because my team is constantly and I
we're constantly trying different
things you know we try video and
pictures and written word I mean written
only is crushing crushing written
only literally transcribing words out of
my mouth and typing them out hitting
post so you got to try different
[__] okay thanks G by the way look what
of course my brother look what uh pack
leader dog said I post the same [__] on
all platforms currently time issue I
totally get it I'm thrilled that you
realize that's not best practices and he
goes and Facebook has grown most by far
you know why there's still a drillion
people this is how day this is how this
is how day trading attention works
there's still millions of people on
Facebook but almost every contemporary
modern Creator is not making content on
Facebook supply and
demand perfect um thank you V
and John do you want to go next thank
you Z of course hey Gary what's up good
to see you John so so I'm starting a new
position um working as a in a financial
role at a real estate
developer and I'm wondering
how can I respect The Confident
confidentially stuff and also like not
jeopardizing the brand
the but also
developing my uh own personal brand and
maybe also the brand of the company so
how can I use maybe LinkedIn while still
respecting the the brand am I clear
you're very clear it's a question I get
asked all the time the way you do that
is by asking the organization for rules
of how you can do it what you're trying
to do is very smart I see it every day I
get asked this all the time you're
you're completely at the mercy of your
employer so you have to ask your
employer for Clear guidelines on what
you're allowed to do on LinkedIn and
explain to them that you're trying to
build it to help the business and then
you'll get a real answer from the
employer to see if they want to suppress
you and not let you build your own brand
thank thank you you're welcome let's get
I agree with Moi before I get out of
here let's grab him also Jack on the
next hangout Hawks I'm going to sneak it
a little bit more but because of my
technical difficulties I want to add 10
minutes to the next one please well
there will we get in here brother I'm
here yes hey let's all call it up our
MMO
call how are you g good brother I miss
you how are
you I'm I'm very good thank you um sorry
to hear about AJ I didn't know that um
yeah
which I never did until like two years
ago so I'm really sorry to hear that
thank you brother as a matter of fact I
don't know if you've heard this the
reason AJ left Vayner media to start
Vayner sports with me was because he was
too stressed doing Vayner media it was
too much HR he didn't like it and so he
he wanted to do something he liked and
that's how vayer Sports got
born oh wow I know that yeah Co tomorrow
is sh's birthday and he couldn't be on
the call today so I wanted to
present him this question why is shiv
not rich
yet let me rephrase so I guess people
that put in let's say a million dollar
in refence they're like well [__] the
market is booming even the nfts are
crushing it and we understand the
long-term Vision but I want to be able
to buy a car or a house yeah um what
what do you what do you think is going
on look I think you know
I think there's a everybody's got a
different strategy of how they want to
build their projects and obviously shiv
you anybody else like I you can imagine
it's an undercurrent every day but you
know I I feel very confident in the way
I'm building this brand and obviously
when you want to create demand for a
digital collectible I saw your comment
yesterday of like less users I think
about this every day I read everything
like I feel very confident in the bricks
that I'm putting down and I think every
IP and whether it's artist or
intellectual property are going to have
different news cycles and different
moments in time and you know I'm
incredibly scared to compromise the way
I'm building this brand and feel very
confident the way that I'm doing it and
obviously I stress if shi's upset or
you're upset or anybody who's upset and
I work on it daily but I can only
navigate the the IP and the demand
creation the way that that I see fit and
you know I I think it's incredibly
challenging to predict market dynamics
it is my responsibility to create
Affinity which will create demand and I
feel like I'm on that Journey um but you
know predicting the markets moments and
things of that nature I think there's a
lot of things that go into different
pricing and a lot of different ways to
play it and I'm playing it the best that
I
can that's awesome thank you I
appreciate it my brother I W wish you a
really healthy happy holiday me too
thank you everybody I'm going to run um
it's great to be with all of you I can't
wait to see all of you again soon uh
come and hang out on Twitch you can see
what I'm doing behind the scenes I'm
going to start building that up I'll see
a bunch of you on Fanatics tonight and
um I'm excited for a bunch of
announcements that are about to come
we're going to have a really active
January as well so I love you we'll talk
to you soon thank you thanks guys cheers
thank
[Music]
you